[Musique]
e
le jeu
nous
e
[Musique]
et
e
où
une
[Musique]
où
oui
[Musique]
c'est tout
[Applaudissements]
là je
[Musique]
moi qui aie
mais non
mon chemin
la main
non
le monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une place place de la ring une femme a
une petite fille s'installe dans le
quartier dans un des immeubles modernes
derrière la place toi c'est geneviève
moi c'est anne do sa part et d'un 20e
[Musique]
un quartier autour d'une place avec des
gens qui vivent là comme partout n'être
pas comme partout peut-être comme plus
jamais elle est comme une clairière dans
la ville moi je vais à l'école et moi je
fais des enquêtes
le recensement
vous souhaitez se prend pour un poulet
dans ce truc de l'islam que fait on
travaille j'ai commencé par les impasses
juste derrière j'ai pas encore une
courage de faire dans cet immeuble de ma
l'impression de rentrer dans un tombeau
on va passer dans deux nouvelles écoles
[Musique]
l'euro de vente dont chloé fille
on dirait une poule qui traverse en tout
cas se laisse pas faire pour les
voitures c'est à l'école c'est comme une
usine mais maintenant c'est chouette
urant c'est pas comme les autres bon on
dirait pas
attention les yeux tu as vu sur la fiche
la rose des sables
c'est ce que c'est
ah oui une fleur du désert en sable
[Musique]
c'est là tu as vu la maison comme
incertaine l'internet c'est un pays si
[Applaudissements]
tu viens donc c'est par ici
naître la place fort de finir bien dans
[Applaudissements]
ta chambre 2-7 malienne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
georges adam
je viens pour le recensement sera bon
aujourd'hui parce que je vois pas bien
clair oblige les risques encourus robert
green qui est madame perrier est ici
vous habitez c'est le parent c'est dans
cette ambiance à blanchard j'ai passé
trente ans ça fait longtemps
ça fait cinq ans
vous avez travaillé ah oui j'ai trouvé
longtemps à côté là une dizaine d'années
j'ai fait deux fois dix ans j'ai
travaillé a compté là puis dans la
douleur des gens d'électricité notre
site électronique il ya deux premiers
livres et vous avez un certificat alors
vous avez un à huy et orrit j'en ai même
deux différemment puisque j'ai deux
maisons j'ai travaillé à deux endroits
différents et pendant dix ans on en
chaque lieu en disant tu des pipes les
ondes d'un an au de quoi m'enfin là je
travaille à côté j'ai très bien ça prend
trois quartiers vous le connaissez bien
à paris j'y suis né mais mais mais mais
comprennent et là et mes parents sont
nés terre ou des orteaux et nous on est
née notre plusieurs et alors on est tous
les titres on peut dire on est parent
vraiment de la rue des orteaux vacants
d'être déjà et moi j'y suis resté oui
vous avez une cuisine oui et non dans
notre cour c'est un chauffage central à
récupération serait ce site-là individus
loin pour son travail il restera une
feuille à remplir ses touches non madame
m
[Musique]
voilà
nouvelle erreur je lâche prise
[Musique]
pour un petit peu non plus sur des
boules jeux sont déjà faits l'idée un
temps difficiles c'est bien de ligue 1
[Musique]
c'est pas les immigrés une seule classe
ouvrière
luttons contre la bourgeoisie qui divise
les ouvriers entre les nationalistes et
enseigne les nationalités immigrés
régularisation de tous les travailleurs
sans papiers français immigrés mêmes
droits politiques pour l'égalité des
droits des ouvriers de toutes
nationalités
m
[Musique]
aimeriez sans papiers sister leur
travail qu'ils crèvent de faim sans
aucun droit au chômage aux profits sur
piles main d'oeuvre pas chère
alors voici 6 7 points voilà pour
l'instant laisse moi tranquille alors
[Musique]
c'est vrai
ap
[Musique]
hahaha
or elle avec l'âge reste à verts contre
l'année
[Musique]
fillon devait attendre
elle commerce et le bonheur sont pas
toujours amis et laroque cas là puisque
pourrait fornication le désordre
l'anarchie et toute la subversion arabes
envoyés mais souhaite aligner malsain on
y parle de tout au long du doigt ses
voisins ses amis de la police
comprennent bien l'argument les chaises
elle au moins mettre chacun dans son
coin à faire ses petites affaires sans
jamais faire deux fois mais un banc
voyez vous c'est indigne et malsain on y
parle de tout on y voit ses bois dont on
fait tenir avis que le vent sera détruit
[Musique]
le danger est présent qui fait face aux
vautours
quels autres chiens errants fait avant
qu'on en veut payer
[Musique]
oh
on va
m
les
la fin
à
[Musique]
les gars sont encore toutes les deux les
autres sur les i
[Applaudissements]
alors papa je peux revenir dans une demi
heure à peu près oui jacques bon
d'accord à thala
je suis née marthe avec lui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand ils vieillissent barricades est-ce
que c'est madame c'est pour le
recensement ma vie ça soit viré parce
que je suis toute seule
le 1er janvier 1968 les amitiés ou ici
vous habitiez ici mais à voir j'avais
une rue alexandre dumas
non parce que j'étais sport payées par
le propriétaire par le propriétaire tim
mamy si j'étais vite de ménage et je
suis très content d'être ici parce que
mon dieu j'ai deux natures le rendre
fenêtre derrière n'y a qu'une chance sur
3 ème étage pour monter vos charmants de
la cam mais ça ne fait rien jusqu'à
présent je peux le faire
on va continuer là vous avez des
diplômes vous avez assez ap genre et ou
chauffage et la femme de ménage puis ils
ont fait une conversion personnelle
alors moi j'étais désigné de partir
alors donc j'ai retrouvé une place à
montrer que j'étais à montreuil et j'ai
appris un métier c'est un 60 59 ans est
dans la maison ça fait longtemps que
vous avez les mêmes voisins où il
voisin en dessous ça fait une homme
quand j'ai des nouveaux voisins
mais c'est indépendant de l'eau s'il
vous savez j'ai des jeunes qui sont
maintenant ils mettent des jeunes parce
que ça va coûter ça m'a pourtant pas
assez les vues
[Musique]
on est tous un bon cheval
sous
wen
je
où
[Musique]
le
lisbonne alice bois lisbonne aurait de
la réunion
[Musique]
et pas loin la place
dans le décor une fille
[Musique]
et
le soleil la mer une belle maison
ça dépend pour qui
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
francis l'avion s'est écrasé jeudi soir
entre la 60e et la préfère que l'on vu
le restant des mois la vie dure
[Musique]
on va
a mis à l'eau
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
m
[Musique]
oui
et
[Musique]
ouais
à
[Musique]
si malin d'avoir oublié il pas le
premier jour d'école ici pour ados
18 mars 71 le peuple de paris se
révoltent contre le républicain la
réaction et la commune
c'est vrai que c'est dans ces quartiers
là que ça s'est passé
parti ouvrier les ateliers des petits
artisans
si aussi élevé de la vie comme sur la
butte rouge
il
fermé le lundi où j'aï rues-des-vignes
eux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
s'ils voient quelque sorte une dame
ça n'empêche pas nicolas la commune est
pas morte aux évasions
tu parles le soleil la mer une nouvelle
maison ils ont commencé à demander
wec je voudrais clore sa méchante dit
après tu sais y'a plus rien ils vont
chanter les vignes avec les fameuses sa
parcelle et déjà les deux immeubles
autrement puis appelleront ça avec nos
démons
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi toi
il est vrai mais ce qu'on sait
mais charles taylor
[Musique]
le passage un peu moins ce qui se passe
est une impasse l'enfer qui s'est
appliqué mais si sony je serai qui
s'appelle casse-tête jour qu'à six jours
y est vous avez trois de ses 3 t et de
la cgt
ils y apprennent rien je vais vous
laisser des fêtes pour le recensement
17h58 les offices et je reviendrai
défection bruit ne les arrange pas un
entretien manquerait ce jeu-là faits
réels atouts de la journée et non
j'étais sûre patrick 70 mais ça fait
vraiment tout ça ici dans cette impasse
le trojan bien que oui il travaille pour
ne pas trop parce qu'il sait qu'on sera
bien oui ça brûlait ça fait deux ans il
va semer la panique
- gérer la fosse moi que je pousse à
courir rapidement handicapé il y avait
les prendra tout le monde courait tous
et loire à cointrin
[Musique]
oui
un bon jour je me reconnais bon se faire
d'illusion sur le quartier parce que
apparemment c'est gentil c'est calme ça
se passe bien mais il faut voir ce qui
se passe derrière elle fut le centre de
filles moi j'ai rencontré des
travailleurs immigrés qui sont ils ont
terrifié quand ils me voient arriver
parce que
bon business et les flics qui débarque
et il m'apporte leurs papiers leur quart
de travail leur passeport
ils vont donc chercher leurs
casernements ce que vous pouvez que donc
ils sont chez eux et qu'ils sont aux
règles parce qu'il ya une hantise du
papier extraordinaire leur demande sans
cesse ans à savoir papier et puis sans
jamais en règle soixante personnes et
jamais en grève
c'est le quartier quoi c'est pas comme
en face la survie de ces nobles comme ça
j'habite tout près j'habite rue de mise
à mal et regardez là mais 100 sauf pour
jardins particuliers
et puis bon ballon voit les chambres
d'enfant c'est céline sauf le dimanche
matin les gens voient les mots bayer au
balcon avec leurs jouets
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
chez lui
[Musique]
et
j'ai foiré vous l'aviez laissée
[Musique]
jamais
m
[Musique]
c'est votre voisin qui les a remplis
paris avait joué chez mon tomasi la
honte et je vois pas bien qu'elle les a
remplis c'est terminé pour vous lors de
l'atelier dans le l'atelier était dans
la rue blanchard il était enfin staff
avait un côté ou là vous savez pas
l'habitude la hausse à 43
ouais à côté il ya déjà longtemps que
j'étais dans les données quand même des
trucs bien et c'était sur une machine
comment vous voudrez j'en ai machine de
presse dépt price était pas mieux au nom
pas trop savez il ya des machins de
comment il a menti formé sur la presse
aussi des du taraudage du perçage
on était bien d'être faire attention
qu'est ce qu'il y avait comme garantie
pour que vous générez un esprit de
paniers qui descend saleh et qui vous
prennent vont mal on en donne un os du
poignet tienne est un pas devant nous ce
qu'on appelle un panier c'est une trappe
qui descend et il s'arrête anouma pour
éviter l'accident
de toute façon comme on avait des
paniers là ça n'allait pas plus loin la
machine s'arrêtait en temps c'était
vraiment bien arrangé parce que
autrement serait difficile un pied des
humains marche quand même hein et du
secret à peine une en arrière là on nous
en sommes dans l'ariège de l'instat
ivement on faisait un mouvement savez
faut suivre le lapi d'âme quand même je
disais vous prenez pour un lapin c'est
parce que à cet immense ça fait
tellement de bruit ça va ya voir s'ils
sont adressés début des grands rouleaux
dassier alors ça fait un bruit on entend
des sept sur la tasse on entend des
côtés lorsque l'on a pas l'habitude
instinctivement on fait la grimace
j'avais à chaque nouvelle attaque
satimo en famille après on prend
l'habitude
enfin ça totalement brouillé
heureusement on savait que j'attends de
paris tu es un on a des gens achètent un
côté nous pour commencer
amaro on arrive à faire ne l'a pas mc
des épaules à chaque tour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour moi je suis fric
[Musique]
tiens si j'en ai pas dire aurevoir moi
je vois faire faire bien avoir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
plus la peine
[Musique]
des bagnoles dans les rues des bagnoles
sur les murs les maisons démolies une
maison à crédit à venir à vendre
instance pour quoi faire
les mômes qu'est ce qui vous fait rire
le tout ça et madame escaut problème
bonjour
[Musique]
nous pas les questions des primes aux
joueurs que j'ai distribué dans les
images que je vais chercher après
attendent moi c'est l'année du
recensement
à quoi ça tient c'est mon travail sont
des chiens dans les semences et
distribue des french ans je vais leur
demander de ta question dans les pieds
non non c'est pas sur la vie de 13 me
demande qui donne des réponses matériel
combien de pièces y habitent ils ont
loupé à rennes
leur installation tu faire un carton
plein quartier spécialement c'est tout
un village de la région de monde se bat
pas tellement de monde en fait je passe
énormément de temps parce que je sais
jamais si les logements sont pas tant
les instantanés pour son travail credo
qui rentrait tard ou qui dorment comme
ceux destinés aux pêcheurs
c'est important ça gère pas prendre part
au combat c'est pas important je vais
faire des bijoux faits pour le street
view maintenant ça m'intéresse
[Musique]
plus tu connais comme aux lois
françaises avant je travaillais pas
assez pour sa chefferie chômage et vous
non croyants la boîte à bonheur changer
le nom de change
vingt quatre ans j'ai 16 ans et que moi
j'étais à l'école j'étais envoyé cinq
ans et comptant l'homme tu vois c'est
pas la joie des billets du troisième
[Musique]
j'ai pas de me balader de suivre les
mêmes trajets des droits les mêmes lieux
vue de d'endroits différents 40 toujours
autour de la plage
[Musique]
elle est petite une série d'immeubles
très différent toi
et les game maisons qui vont bientôt
être démoli j'allais des immeubles
modernes
je fais le tour jusqu'au 13e 14e et
alors là c'est un paysage pour faire la
différence entre un doute quand on est
en bas un paysage complètement différent
on ne peut pas avoir du tout quand on
est en bas évasion à vendre
[Musique]
soleil la mer
une belle maison à papa
[Musique]
et
mais
[Musique]
jean frère ils me voient pas leurs
portes
où je trouve le gardien
[Musique]
madame
j'ai bien pour le recensement j'ai
besoin de voir les locataires montée
madame moi j'attends mon cul mais plus
on ne peut pas des choses je voulais
monter l'échelle des priorités avait un
beau jardin là mais bon je vous dirai
pas dehors qu'ils ont je crois à la
campagne la campagne j'ai une vigne qui
produit et des belles roses celestis
jour j'attendais pilon je pense qu'il a
créé
et vous passeront leur transport leur
essence mans alors il faut que sa voix
les locataires là j'ai écouté parts
d'aia trois locataires qu'ils sont là
alors vous pouvez monter
allez les voir en premier au deuxième et
peut-être qu'elle a eu nos troisième et
parle à quelqu'un et par là par là
écoutez là je sais pas l'art bayane à la
baille sont là il ya personne là il ya
bien sûr en valais qu'il a ou non plus
se tient les placards ya et que tu vas
te faire rayonner les liens au quotidien
n'avait pas bougé du banc
[Musique]
à remplir
si vous les avez pas remplies bon les
français conscients
s'il n'est pas là voulait on n'est pas
là un premier un sapin au fond d'une
cour
à la chaussée dans un
mais un jour
[Musique]
si oui je suis allé à côté mais y'a
quelqu'un appelle ça du travail
oui enfin son plus jeune on n'y a pas de
famille pour le recensement
monsieur
bonjour monsieur au jeune homme
c'est paulo sens m'en veulent là plus
personne
ce qu'ont tous partis ya plus personne
ce fou
[Musique]
et
je les remplirait je ne déposerai chez
concierge
c'est pas un vrai concierge eux qui
travaillent dans la journée donc je sois
plus tôt après apprécié ça c'est vous
que j'ai vu sur la place est toujours
vous donniez des photos oui je sais ça
c'est dit si vous voulez vous les
regardez de deux pavillons passé la
première photo existe en arrivant dans
le quartier il ya un peu plus d'un an
alors si une photo je reste à
l'extérieur même les gens du quartier se
tiennent comme étrangers les vieux des
gens fauchés l'école vitruve là ils ont
monté un cercle pour donner des
représentations à l'extérieur il ça
c'est la première fois qu'ils sont
sortis de l'école
alors ça c'est les boulistes
oui si les goliaths sinon c'est le
quotidien de la place mais alors l'autre
jour je les montre et justement aux
boulistes qui voulez vous voulez les
voir en choisir pour en avoir pour eux
alors qu'un tunnel tristement dire qu'il
prenne une photo pour un copain pour
pour la veuve de celui-là qui est mort
bon celui-là aussi nice est vivant après
que c'était du shit et michel roth
les africaines complètement
insaisissable quoi parce que sont les
seuls étrangers qui ne s'arrête pas sur
la fin et je joue pas au bout le travail
dans les ateliers il faut manger et au
final on peut pas même pas les dents
dans les cafés ou y songez pas si vous
avez vu mais je les vois de 13 ans a
laissé à leurs courses près de
terre-neuve que des locales du fruit pur
et là aussi c'est fermé enfin on sait
pas du tout parce qu un magasin près de
l'inscription de la commune
ah oui bah les boulistes
je vous connais vous nos enfants si tu y
joues bah oui et alors c'est les grands
qui leur apprennent qu ils font ils font
comme les grands cdc les vrais jeux
finalement et ça c'est marcel sacré
marcel je le connais je les ressens si
c'est utile et des bijoux oui tu as
beaucoup bourlingué qui s'adresse à vous
directement tête huit fosses tutoyer
ticks simplement il fait fumer un peu
trop quelques-unes ont placé là elle est
là quoi et les boulistes a l'impression
qu'ils sont là tout le temps mais c'est
des gars qui travaillent souvent la nuit
qui sont des 3min et sur souvent là où
on attendait l'impression qu'ils sont en
vacances perpétuer mais c'est jamais les
mêmes non plus courant et ça c'est à
l'automne à la rentrée des vacances
alors il y avait beaucoup plus de monde
tous les portugais déjà été moi même
invité par un portugais qui travaillent
ici dans le bâtiment ça a permis de
mieux comprendre ce que c'était que de
bosser comme ça à l'étranger parce que
j'avais assisté au départ du gars qui
revenait en france pour bosser un an il
n'en pouvait plus tôt il en avait marre
mais il savait aussi que c'était la
seule solution
la lumière est belle
[Musique]
e
vous avez réussi à les réunir les flics
vous avez toute cette que thomas pied de
nez en métal il m'a bien donné
j'espère que vous avez raison je suis
passé je sais ça correspond moi je suis
passé pour voir le monsieur du deuxième
il a d'ailleurs il m'est arrivé une
histoire
il m'a mise en garde contre des
squatteurs qui habitait au quatrième as
dit surtout attention
moi je vous conseille de ne pas y aller
je savais pas qu est-ce qui habitent là
il va vous arriver tatchoum zone passe
on sait jamais qui sait si jamais les
mêmes car il m'a dit surtout les criez
pas au secours parce que personne ne
viendra il faut crier au feu et alors je
me suis trouvé en face d'une fille qui
avait extrêmement peur qui remonte dans
ses bras il n'y avait rien dans la pièce
c'était plutôt triste et savait rien
avoir du tout avec le spectacle que ma
vie les antilles ce monsieur n'à qu'à
lille au deuxième étage
ils sont mesquins ils ont fait et même
un attroupement ici dans mon couloir en
disant qu'il fallait absolument mettre à
la porte ces gens là il nous a dit allez
voir le commissaire
ils ont été au commissariat tout mais ne
peuvent rien faire il faut dire corps de
ceux là nous vivons ici comme dans une
petite campagne c'est quelque chose de
merveilleux
voyez il ya la petite place de réunions
où vont tous nos petits vieux m'a manqué
89 ans qui va se promener sur 7
place où tout le monde se connaît et
vous vous craignez rien pour les
expulsions ici n'est ce pas il ya
beaucoup de petits retraités et c'est
très difficile pour d'aller à lyon parce
que moi aussi je vais faire la retraite
est ce le cas de terre et si c'était
vendu ici je vois un problème problème
eh ben ça y est arrivé reid
alors ça c'est cinq centimes 5 10 15
en vingt cinq ans à 110,90 il apprend à
les revoir
j'ai des problèmes avec les appartements
que j'ai recensé en france on m'a dit
que vous y appartiennent ces dépôts à
l'éditeur je ne crois pas comment la
course s'est juste eu recours au bois
puis de matériel c'est franchement ça
fait longtemps fait ce travail depuis
tout jeune je m'en fais ça va servir
je suis cécile bien ça va commencer mon
père que deux paires en 6 ans et 7 067
points métier clubs pros comme ça j'ai
fait ça exprès
et voilà comment je savais pas quel rôle
d'un tatoueur mobile à ce que j'ai
depuis 20 ans compères acheté il ya
vingt ans la sacem je voyais l'eau gelée
rastek jusqu'à la retraite
ça marche m donc arrête toujours été
dans le quartier sait comment il avait
choisi mon quartier mais non sans que ce
soit salade était déjà là quand il est
venu alors c'est pour ça qu'il a repris
même quartier c'est des familles le
frère mais il me semble qu'il ya pas mal
de gens qui travaillent c'est ce qu'il
est en prison
dans la rue des vignoles oui bon on fait
jouer au passage j'ai pas tellement le
temps c'est le temps qui vous
puis toute la journée dans la guitare de
tout cela on peut préférer aux éditeurs
laisser travailler les travailleurs
qu'on croise sur la place ils sortent
d'une usine la potée il faut déjà scellé
[Musique]
en vingt ans
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'essaie lancement tout autour de la
place je vois 36 vues du favori plus en
plus j'en profite pas tellement sûr je
trouve el país moi je travaille moi même
à l'aco ce que je pars le matin et
rentrent le soir tout ça ou c'est le cas
lueur des phares de voiture
j'en suis un peu le symbole au dimanche
aucun n'a vraiment un décor de théâtre
c'est c'est les autres qui vont être
démolis et pourtant c'est la porte qui
sont des cuisines
il sautait sur la terre je décollais mal
à part les joueurs de boules parce que
là tu peux doublej c'est vrai que lui
dit si on se rend compte en fait et
aucun aucune relation entre tous ces
moments d quand on est en bas au
contraire on passe mais les gens les ans
les entend on a l'impression d'être
proche mais c'est parfaitement miroir
ado tu veux venir voir les photos ici
toutes les avenues ces photos c'est un
photographe qui habite sur la place le
rayon que je ressens c'est je regarde la
suisse et l'immeuble carrico l'afrique
c'est fowler leurs courses à sylvain
larue de terre-neuve magasin à côté
d'elle
l'inscription comme une émeraude liste
avec ses bretelles c'est un portugais
souffre cependant comment
et aussi un coup tu la mare aux femmes
et on rencontre souvent soit la touche à
pois
cette fumée du boulot ailleurs malgré
les bronzes l'euro c'est l'un qui balaye
tu avais de le clos des vignes ce que ça
sera c'est ça c'est le celui qui envoie
les pigeons ah bon si rien on dirait un
capitaine de bateau qui ont suivi plus
un petit chariot des chardons par les
mines continuent avec disons ça c'est
les horaires de ces fonds quand tu fais
brûler
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non madame bonjour toulousain je viens
vous apporter des feuilles pour le
recensement devrait savoir combien vous
êtes ici pour bako vous adresserez là au
café au coin là où sollied à caussade où
à côté
oui
il appartient
[Musique]
comment
m
les envois
[Musique]
la maison a fermé le mercredi 6 un gros
chien d'alarmé non la voix souvent rien
je crois que l'on peut croiser la forme
et la pâte à renvoyer chez eux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hâtez-vous l'artois la cclat à la balle
s'est montré là bas la spla par la sukuk
ou non ça va pas là bas et que parmi
d'entraînement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un bon jour si vous habitez là
encore les voisins
j'avais dans les jambes à face à la
deuxième phase des travaux
j'hésiterais presque visite à regarder
quoi lutter contre le chômage et
premier à danser le tango
c'est qu'il ya une énorme sur le
quartier le bas tous les instruments du
quartier sur le 20e c'est à dire ici on
se prend vite rue
oui des vignobles et son terrain
d'aventuré délégués du parti moratoire
ça c'était dans la pub on va aller ça
lui va bientôt alors ça dure
oui alors c'est votre cas vous êtes
toujours c'est un peu dur on en profite
tout c'est que l'hiver sera pareil
mercredi matin la place que parce qu'à
nous soyez ni ses frais savez que j'ai
appris que vous l'ayez pas fait ici une
aventure pas si c'est que c'est pas si
on fait tout étant tous les ans une
petite heure quand on appelle ça une
caravane on pense à mes enfants ait pu
tomber si ceux ci sont la grille
gagnante rappelle que l'état y avait
l'école l'aquarelle à l'abri bernard
madoff avait un kiosque mais on dit en
ces points alors on se croirait au match
aller mais on dirait la nôtre quoi je
m'empresse cannes ou quoi on l'a presque
acheter enfin ma famille est à la
prochaine
la place c'est presque à nous notre coin
depuis le temps on l'a presque acheter
[Musique]
et
non
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
oh
et
[Musique]